the target was clear the united arab
emirates striking back against healthy
missile bases in yemen it's the latest
retaliation after debris from a healthy
missile attack earlier on monday landed
in a remote part of abu dhabi
critical installations in abu dhabi were
targeted by a number of ballistic
missiles also the emirate of dubai was
targeted by a number of drones the
operation by the grace of god hit its
targets with high precision
emergency officials say airports are
operating as normal and the healthy
attack did not have an impact
but these strikes coincide with the
israeli president's first visit to abu
badi another time of increased fighting
between the houthis and the saudi
coalition in yemen
we reiterate that the enemy state the
united arab emirates will remain an
unsafe country so long as they continue
with their belligerence against our
beloved yemeni people
earlier this month a healthy drone
strike on the uaa's capital killed three
people on sunday the u.s state
department urged americans to reconsider
any travel to the united arab emirates
citing threats of missile attacks
the situation is becoming more dangerous
because the nature of weaponry that's
being used in these attacks is becoming
more deadly
and that's all the more reason why one
hopes that the parties will be able to
find some way to resolve this contract
this conflict
but diplomacy has yet to solve this
regional conflict that has been going on
for years and created the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
al-jazeera
sanaa